hey everyone in honor of zelda's 35th
birthday we decided now would be a good
time to look back at the best trailers
and commercials from the series history
if you like this video then we have more
zelda content on the way so consider
subscribing
without further ado let's jump right in
did you see the latest nintendo
newsletter whoa
nice graphics i'd like to get my hands
on that game you mean you haven't played
it yet
we can play it on my nintendo
entertainment system it's the legend
that zelda and it's really rad
those creatures from ganon are pretty
bad octorox tech types
but with your help our hero pulls
through yeah
go link yeah get something awesome
intense the nintendo entertainment
system your parents help you hook it up
the legend of zelda sold separate
watch zelda become a legend on your
nintendo entertainment system
zelda
rocks which way
[Music]
a never-ending adventure new for your
nintendo entertainment system
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
only from nintendo now you're playing
with power
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
down with zelda from the very start i
got the heart it's march the blade apart
with zelda
[Music]
with the plan cause the power's in my
head and the powers in my head touch it
down with zelda
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the first time i saw you i knew we'd be
linked forever
for you i traveled to the four corners
of the world
i faced adversity i became a hero
then i saved your kingdom dad
yes zelda are you mixing me up with the
princess again
hard to say you're both pretty magical
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
radio zelda is now transmitting he's
playing
he's playing i knew it just a reminder
72 hours remaining until the end of the
world
i knew it was coming i knew it was
coming
local time 12 30 and if you're listening
he's gonna make it i know he's gonna
make it i'm not sure how to say this but
there's just not a lot of time left
you think he's gonna make it i hope so
and hey listen kid
i don't know if you can hear me but
you're all we've got
so good luck play hard
[Music]
you've been tuned into radio zelda
[Music]
you're listening to radio zelda night's
fall this isn't good
and with less than six hours left he's
almost got it i think we should
take some phone calls hello caller
hello are you there yes i'm here go
ahead
we're listening i just believe
mom i love you and dad i miss you
[Music]
i'm sorry it's okay i hope that kid wins
[Music]
i really do hey kid
i'm using all my minutes we're all
pulling for you so if you're listening
hang in there i know you got the weight
of the world on your shoulders
hey man what's going on waiting for the
moon to drop
don't forget it's all about the weight
of the moon do you believe
in angels this has been a broadcast of
radio zelda
[Music]
good night kid
[Music]
[Music]
zelda returns the game boy color in an
adventure too big for just one game
rated e for everyone each game sold
separately get into it
[Music]
him
[Music]
a legend a legend
held dearly by the royal family
that tells of a boy who became a man
he embarked on a great journey
to the deepest darkest corners of the
earth
battling the forces of evil
testing the limits of his world
all to fulfill his destiny
which is above all else
[Music]
for with this sword i have unleashed an
evil wind that has taken our beloved
princess
our journey is fraught with danger but
together we four might overcome the
mage's dark magic
only then will all the maidens be
released
and our princess once again be rescued
who are you the legend of zelda four
swords adventures only for nintendo
gamecube
rated e for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
shhh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
it's
next stop hyrule link and zelda team up
in an all-new epic adventure the legend
of zelda
spirit tracks
[Music]
every legend has an origin every hero
has a history
embark on an adventure 25 years in the
making
and shape the destiny of a world where
the only hope for the future
lies in the secrets of the past
[Music]
this is where it all begins prepare to
play your part
the legend of zelda skyward sword only
for we
[Music]
[Music]
ah
to become a legend you must be willing
to risk everything
there is no challenge you can't overcome
no danger you can't escape
and no dungeon you can't solve you can
use link's new powers in an all-new
adventure to conquer hyrule's ancient
dungeons the legend of zelda a link
between worlds
only available on nintendo 3ds and 2ds e
for everyone
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sanchez
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the history of the royal family of
hyrule
is also the history of the calamity
ganon
a primal evil that has endured over the
[Music]
ages
[Music]
so
[Music]
that look on your face tells me that you
have no recollection of me however
i think you are now ready ready to hear
what happened
100 years ago
everything i've done up until now
it was more for nothing
[Music]
here it comes
[Music]
you must save her my daughter
[Music]
open your eyes
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
and there you have it any trailers or
commercials we missed let us know in the
comments below
for all the latest on skyward sword hd
breath of the wild sequel and all things
zelda stay tuned to gamespot
[Music]
you